um leading international venue for
collaborative research and theoretical
computer science every semester we run
two programs that run the length of the
semester and each of those programs has
one boot camp and three workshops this
Workshop is part of the program on graph
limits and processes on networks and is
the third and final Workshop of the
program on the economics of Networks
I'd like to give a special thanks to the
organizers of the workshop
Alex slipkins Ben golub
Nicole and marlika
azaraj malikian
um and thank you very much for
organizing a great Workshop so thank you
[Applause]
um a few Logistics
um we will provide food during breaks
and before the first talk of the morning
um but you're on your own for lunch but
fortunately Berkeley has many close-by
eateries that you can make use of we ask
that you not bring food into the
auditorium though and if you like there
are lockers on the opposite side of this
floor where you can store your items
when you're away
um
Omid Farr is our videographer and he'll
help speakers get set up for for talks
and today's event is hybrid so if you're
in the room you can just raise your hand
and ask a question if you're attending
via Zoom you can use the Q a and the
session chair will
um we'll ask your question on your
behalf and I'd also like to give a
special thanks to our events team I
think it was Kalani was it you who did
most of the organizing it was Elizabeth
right
okay Elizabeth one who did most of the
organizing and planning for the workshop
including most of the accommodations for
the additional visitors that we have so
thank you Elizabeth
um and I will hand things over to Alex
who will give a little intro to the
workshop welcome
I I don't have a whole lot to say I mean
thanks all for coming I'm very excited
about the you know lineup of speakers
both individually and assertive like
representative of the field or like
what's going on in this field
uh I hope and and the intent is that
like we will not only like listen to
each other as talks but also like talk
and hang out
so and uh another thing I guess most
stocks will be in person except for like
uh morning session tomorrow which will
be entirely virtual and Nicole was going
to say something about that
yeah I think so we had
through unable to join us physically
um and so we put all of their that's
awesome uh
um Evan Sadler and Dean Eckles and so we
put all of their talks in the morning
tomorrow so that's going to be a fully
virtual session uh we did that
intentionally so that if you wanted to
you could attend it in your hotel rooms
or at a coffee shop using your
headphones
um there the session will be on gather
town so it's going to be I hope more
interactive than a typical virtual
session so you can go um walk around and
talk to people and the speakers at least
Evan and Dean have committed to being
present in gather town during the
30-minute break between the first two
talks and the third talk so if you want
to interact with them
just grab your laptop and go somewhere
quiet and walk over to them and talk to
them it will also be streamed in this
room so if you prefer to watch it in an
auditorium with other people you can you
can do that as well
um and if you have any questions about
all of this you can ask me there's also
a link from the seminar website to a
very like you know
1990s website that I created that
explains how to access all of the talks
virtually
Yes actually this session share now
thanks everyone for joining so the theme
today for the talks are learning uh and
networks and the first talk would be by
Kevin hey who will talk about uh
learning from viral content
[Music]
foreign
let me say thanks to organizers for food
and guidance program and for not having
you here thank you all for coming to the
talk
um this is um a new joint project with
Krishna called learning from viral
content so we begin with the observation
that you know in the past decade viral
content social media platforms has
emerged as a prominent source of news
for many people
and a common feature here is that people
you know log on to these platforms and
they see stories in new seats
the stories that get to go into these
news feeds depend on previous users
actions
Twitter for example the Twitter home
page you know selects which tweets to
show you on the basis of how many times
these tweets have been liked and
retweeted by previous users right and
they also display a special section for
the trending Stories the tweets that
have been you know most liked or
retreated
think about Reddit reddit's front page
shows you a list of the most highly
uploaded content so in these examples
there's some kind of endorsement actions
the users can perform be it retreating
or liking on Twitter be it uploading on
Reddit
and these endorsement actions affect
what kinds of stories future users have
to see in their use
of course these kinds of user actions
only tell half the story the other half
the story for these platforms is that
they're in the background there's some
kind of platform algorithm
that determines how these user actions
affect what future users see in
particular right platform algorithm has
to determine how much weight is given to
virality in other words the current
popularity of the various stories in
sampling stories to you know to to put
into these news
you know for example different
iterations of the Twitter design gave
different levels of emphasis to these
trending trending tweets or popular
tweets you can imagine you know maybe a
more viral version of Twitter
where the algorithm assigns higher
weight
to how much a tree has been liked before
in terms of whether it gets to go into
your news feed or you can imagine less
viral version
and also you know reddit's ordering
algorithm for post has also evolved over
decade nowadays it's not simply a
descending sort of you know how many
times different posts have been uploaded
and so today I want to show you a model
and equilibrium model where users are
going to interact with news stories
and
this project is basically going to focus
on the trade-offs for social learning
when the platform shows more viral
content in news feeds as opposed to more
random content now why is this an
important question well this analysis
relates to a recent policy debate did
these new cities that push viral content
facilitate the spread of false
information about you know Public Health
politics and so forth to understand this
question we must first understand what
are the pros and cons for social
learning in terms of how viral these
news feeds are like what are the
advantages and disadvantages for social
learning when we make these um the
sampling of these news feeds more or
less so let me quickly show you the
basic mechanism right so I want to
highlight at a very
um heuristic and high level you know
some intuition for the pros and cons of
having a more viral use and then the
rest of the talk will be focused on
developing a formal model and
formalizing this intuition
what's the advantage of having a more
biology well the advantage is you get to
convey more information with just a few
stories
what I mean by that well if you use
Reddit you might have the experience
that reading a few from page stories
gives you a lot more information than
reading a few random stories
why is that well part of the reason is
that if you see a positive story in a
viral news a news feed that's select on
the basis of how many times it's been
uploaded let's say
the fact that the positive story is in
your feed that carries more information
than merely the realization of a single
signal
you should account for selection the
stories which go into these viral news
feeds are the ones which have been
frequently upvoted by previous users
so the fact that this positive stories
in your news feed tells you something
about the previous people's upvoting
behavior now why did these previous
users upvote the story
it might be because they have some
positive type information it might be
because they saw some other positive
stories in their own news feeds which
are not present in your own in your
music today but whatever the reason
right there's some kind of hidden
information which you're not directly
observing but you can make indirect
inference about
by virtue of this positive story haven't
been upvoted enough to land in your
music
and that's some kind of inference that
you cannot draw by observing just random
you know signals and that's the sense in
which reading a few like you know front
page stories a few stories select on the
basis of the of their virality that
gives you more information lets you
develop stronger beliefs than observing
the same number of you know random
signals and when you say positive here
it's implicit that there's some issue
that we're trying to approve some kind
of single axis yeah sorry I I'm
implicitly thinking about a binary state
of the world where the state is either
positive or negative I'm just using that
as an example that's right
um good and so so that's the advantage
or that that might be one reason why we
might we might want to have a more Buy
on YouTube we sort of convey more
information with just a few stories but
what's the downside what might be a
disadvantage of having a mobile USB well
you can sort of generate these bad
steady states with wrong stories
dominates even for rational users what I
mean is it could be the case that most
of the content on the platform are
correct
but
you know the incorrect story can still
be more popular and so after waving by
popularity I end up showing these
incorrect stories more frequently to
users
and so these bad statistics have this
they can sort of self-perpetuate right
like people can see these incorrect
negative stories they rationally come to
believe this day must be negative
therefore they upload these native
stories thinking that they're correct
that assigns additional popularity
points to these incorrect stories they
can show more so and so forth and this
is kind of a dynamic that many tech
companies have realized like you know
Reddit in this design blog back in 2009
realized that this kind of kind of a
feedback loop that one should worry
about if we were to display content
heavily weighed by virality by how many
times it's been uploaded or so forth
right and so the rest and that's sort of
like you know a disadvantage of having
more viral usually the rest of time will
be about formalizing these intuition in
an equilibrium model where agents are
forming Bayesian Beauties after seeing
the new CN acting rash
so first our outline this talk is I'll
tell you about this model of equilibrium
learning and sharing on social media
um then I will tell you about sort of
you know you know if you were to fix a
particular behavior of the users a
particular way that they share and what
what's going to happen on in the long
run on the platform we'll call those
steady States and finally return to
equilibrium right so when do we get
these misleading steady state these
situations where wrong stories that tend
to be the ones that get shared in
equilibrium
so let me tell you the model so there's
some unknown state of nature which you
see the negative or positive equally
likely there's a finite group of n
agents in positions one through n and
these n agents moving order
the agents don't know their own position
basically the end agents are randomly
assigned to these impositions equally
likely so from now on I'll refer I'll
say agent I to mean the aid the agent
who was assigned into the ice position
so agent in position I has a private
signal which we can interpret a new
story s i which is also also either
negative or positive
and there's going to be some probability
Q with which each of these story is
going to match the state of the state of
nature Omega
and this probability of matching States
we're going to call this the story
Precision it's a number between half and
one
the first thing that's going to happen
is Agent I will post their story SI onto
the platform
and we're going to keep track of an
integer for each story called a
popularity School
we're going to start every newly posted
story at a store of positive one and
we'll see how the score increases later
on
agent9 in addition to seeing and posting
this story as I it's also going to see a
news feed consisting of capital K
stories posted by others which is
sampled somehow based on those stories
current popularity scores and later I'll
tell you a bit more about how the sample
is done
and we're going to assume that you do
not see the popularity or the arrival
time of the story you simply see whether
a story is positive or negative okay so
you basically see a new speed of things
which are either negative or positive
and okay there's one more wrinkle which
is if I need to show you a new co5
stories and your agents three okay I
don't have three story I don't have five
stories to show you so let's just forget
this see in the news feed thing for the
first K agents
from this news feed consisting of
capital case stories you're going to
share see stories from the news feed
every time you share a story you
increase its popularity score by one
why do you want to share things um
what's your objective here well you get
positive utility some number U bigger
than zero every time you share a story
which correctly matches this data nature
so you want to look at the stories in
your news feed think about why you think
the state of nature is and share those
stories which you think matches it
let me illustrate how this model I guess
Works
um with an example right so imagine so
this is how it would look like and when
K is 3 and C is one so people see three
things share one thing
so imagine five agents have moved and so
you know now my uh my database the
platform database has contained five
stories I'm going to use a green color
to refer to a positive story and a red
color and Native story and I'm writing
here the current popularity score of
each story
this here I'm simply showing what's in
the database of the platform this is not
what agency what does agency agent 6
sees their own private signal which
let's say it's positive and they're also
going to see a news feed so I'm going to
somehow sample three stories out of
those five and place that into a new
let's say I sample stories three one and
four
okay
as I said before you don't get to see
the score of those stories just know
that you've got two positive stories and
one negative story in your newsfeed and
also I'm putting parentheses around at
things like S4 because you also don't
get to know that you know that this is
Agent four Sigma you don't get to know
that you don't know the arrival time of
the store you just know you know from
the perspective of player six okay I've
got one positive story and I've got
which is my private signal and I've got
two out of three parts of stories in my
list
on the basis of that information I'm
going to share one of those three
stories let's say I shared this one in
the middle what happens when I share
well I increase its score right its
score was two when person six shares
that this score goes up
and then we basically keep going for our
future agents right so I mean player
seven arrives how has the world changed
well player six six story gets posted
onto the platform and also you know this
score has to increase by one due to the
sharing action here and then we're going
to use this new set of scores so samples
three stories for this person and let's
say this person has a private student
that's negative and maybe we sample some
stories and then person seven month is I
want to share and so
any questions about how this model looks
so in all the examples that you
mentioned you can see the popularity a
score yeah but in your model and you
decided to hide it why yeah very good I
think that's largely for trackability
reason I think we're calling these
things popularity score but I guess in
the back of my it's some kind of metric
that the platform is keeping track of
Perhaps it is not literally the number
of times it's been shared but maybe
let's say you know they show the blurb
of a story you must click a button to
read the full story it's some Metric
which the platform knows about in the
background but that's a metric that you
don't really get to see as it user
foreign
are the same thing yes
so I decided to share one of them but
nevertheless the score of only one of
them is going to increase after my
action yes
how can you disentangle these two things
oh okay okay because like one I'm going
to yes like for me as a player six those
two stories are exactly the same but in
equilibrium only one score is going
there so you have Multiplicity
in terms of uh with a scroll which ones
yes yes yes yes in um in our model it
actually doesn't matter because in the
end what really matters is the total
populates were assigned to stories of a
particular couple of a particular
that's and some matter it so it doesn't
actually matter where you share this one
or this one so you don't need to keep
track of the score of this one but just
of the green it turns out the model is
such that I just I don't know so it
actually says
[Music]
and then so another question like the
objective is to match the state but
again some of the the application that
you uh have in mind that you actually
want to share the one with the I guess
popularity oh you're saying something
like maybe I want to share things and I
want the thing I should really share or
something like that our current guess is
an objective like that might also be
okay like since I behave similarly
because from your perspective like the
thing which more likely to be correct
it's also the one that's more likely to
be
the answer is that they made this what
we're doing here will remain equilibrium
but there may be other maybe stranger
could Liberia where people
do some kind of strange coordination
thing like I decide to only share native
stories or something like that like
everybody decides to coordinate a
particular way
can you remind me how my own story
enters so if if agent six cell has its
own story one how does favor how does
this enter in his decision which of
these three stories to share uh well
it will enter well in in equilibrium
person 6 knows how you know this story
being positive like what this means
about the state state of nature and so
person six must form some sort of
patient belief and this piece of
information is part of the puzzle of
that Asian be development but then he
can only share one of the three stories
in his new sweet he can't share his own
story yeah his own story is mechanically
always posted onto battle
I see do you do your decisions which of
the news fee stories
okay but the fact that only the total
number matters it looks a little like a
polio earned with red and green balls
what's that it looks a little like a
polia earned this red and green yes in
the end you'll look something like a
poliary yeah it's related in some type
of polygraphy
um very good so let me say a few more
more words about how the sampling is
done right so
um right so the platform the key
parameter here is parameter called the
virality weight which is a a number
Lambda between zero and one that
determines how those capital K stories
get sampled
so here's how it's done for each slot in
the news feed with probability Lambda
I'm going to sample a story with
probabilities proportional to the the
popularities the popularity score of the
stories
what's the complementary probability I'm
going to sample a story uniformly at
random out of the set of all stories
and for Simplicity we're going to sample
with replacement in sometimes not too
important if the pool of store is very
large
foreign
so is the sampling agnostic to the
platform's estimate of what the private
signal is yes it is agnostic of the yes
okay so so this is how it sounds
um so
if I have sorry I have Lambda equals
zero I'm always sampling uniformly at
random if Lambda is equal to one I'm
always sampling you know proportional to
popularity score intermediate values
Lambda interplates you can use suitcase
higher Lambda it's like I'm I'm putting
heavier weight on on the popularity
score therefore more viral use
so what do strategies look like what do
players see players see their private
signal s and they see a news on the news
feed basically they can say okay they're
little K out of capital K positive
stories okay on the basis of these two
pieces of information they have to
decide okay how many of the positive
stories do I want to share so the
strategy it must tell me you know on the
basis of this as my private signal and
this K should I share zero one two or up
to C positive stories
okay we should consider mixed strategies
so really it's a mixture over those
numbers
remember you you would always rationally
choose to share a total of capital c
story so you know if I if you tell me
how many positive ones you're sharing
the rest is you know how many negative
ones you share
let's focus on these State symmetric
strategies which treat positive and
negative stories symmetrically
now the first question is if everyone
were to use a particular stasometric
strategy Sigma which may not be in any
sense equilibrium more optimal what
would happen on the platform in the long
run
well given a state Omega I'm going to
keep track of a number called viral
accuracy XT that's the viral accuracy XT
after TX that's what fraction of the
total popularity score are assigned to
the state matching stories so add up the
total popularity score of those same
matching stories divided by total
popular score of all stories that number
is some number between zero and one that
that's XT bioaccuracy at time t
imagine infinite Society where all
agents after K plus one use the
particular strategy Sigma what we get is
a stochastic process of bioaccuracy why
is the stochastic process well we got
this Randomness in the signal
realization we call this Randomness in
the the sampling of the stories for
instance
a point x star such that x t converges X
star with positive probability I'm going
to call that a steady state of the
strategy signal
basically the idea is you know what does
convergence mean it means the fraction
of total popularity score on those State
matching stories remains close to X Star
right as I sort of add fresh stories
period after period as I do this kind of
sampling period after period And as
people always use the sigma to determine
one
but first we talked about indeed we have
convergence next
okay this is the convergence result
given any strategy Sigma
there is a finite set of steady states
which I'll call Cap X star so that
almost surely
XT in fact converges to one of these 10
states
so almost surely we do have bioaccuracy
convergence but in general x-star might
not cap X star might not be a Singleton
there might be multiple points in there
that is x t the process could convert to
you know this limit or that one
depending on you know what happens early
on in the process for example
Randomness in the signal sampling you
know making you convert to different to
different limits to different statuses
how do I care try X XR the set of points
which get converged to with positive
probability for the particular strategy
Sigma
we're going to look at this function
that I'm going to call the inflow
accuracy function associated with the
strategy Sigma I'm going to verbally
describe to you what this is and
hopefully that's clear if now we'll look
at the formal definition I'll call this
you know you know Phi Sigma X this is
the inflow accuracy function associated
with the strategy Sigma evaluated at x
what this thing basically is it's saying
okay imagine today's bioaccuracy is is X
okay and also let's imagine Q fraction
of the stories are matching to stay on
the platform in general remember x and q
might be different numbers right because
Q is the fractional stories that matches
today and X is like the popularity
weighted fraction of story that matches
when a new person comes on the platform
that person must increase the total
popularity score by C plus one why the
person must post a new story that story
has a score of one when it's posted the
person must share C stories increasing
each of their popularity by one point
each so overall total popularity score
has to go up by C plus one
the inflow accuracy function asks well
what fraction of those C plus one extra
points of popularity are expected to be
assigned to the state matching stories
and again this is excitation because
there's some Randomness in the
realization of this new s story there's
some Randomness in sampling
and if you think about this what this
function is doing intuitively you think
that well fixed points of this inflow
axis function really ought to be natural
candidates or steady state right if I
tell you that whenever 70 of the score
on the same action stories then 70 of
the incoming score would again be on the
same action story then we somehow should
stay at 70.
you say exactly cute remind us what Q is
oh Q is the accuracy of the each
individual story
and and the reason why this is true that
this is basically a lot of large numbers
right I keep adding stories to the
platform by law of large numbers in the
end it must be roughly Q fraction of the
stories that are actually statement
uh very good and so and and this and if
this were true if this were true if the
fixed points are in fact the steady
state that would be great right because
it's much easier to study fixed points
of the thing than to study like steady
stage right steady stage the limit of
some crazy stochastic process fixed
points is no fixed point the polynomial
function
and the next result basically tells you
this is basically true it's using a
stochastic approximation tools to
establish that equivalence provided a
particular condition post provided that
fixed point is not unstable from both
sides
what's a promo statement
is that fixed point of the inflow
accuracy function
and
either whenever I am slightly below but
whenever I'm studying a ball back star
bio accuracy tends to go down
or whenever I am slightly below x-star
viral actually tends to go up if while
these two condition holds then X star is
in fact a steady state that is the
stochastic process converges there with
some strictly positive probability
conversely if I have a steady state it
must be a fixed point
the most surprising part of this claim
by the way
is that a fixed point of inflow axis
function which is stable from only one
side
okay which is usually called a touch
point it's also reached by XC with
positive probability because right it's
it's an or here I don't need to be still
from both sides it just needs to be
stable from one side and then it's a
fixed form
and what this tells you is that somehow
the distribution of a steady state
changes discontinuously like you know
imagine you know think about the
distribution of steady States as index
by parameter like Lambda right so as I
change Lambda at some point like you
know a new
um a new fixed point will arise and that
new fixed point where it appears it's
going to be a touch point
so if I were to ask what's the
probability of converging the sarcastic
process converges somewhere in that
neighborhood
along the limit of these values of
Lambda answered zero zero zero zero zero
and suddenly ten percent
right because these these touch points
they have a strictly positive
probability of being reached that's the
definition of a steady state so they
have this kind of discontinuity
um at these and this turns out to be
important for some technical reason but
I have the skill for the latest so I
kind of expected this proof to go
through
a uh a result that's going to say like
the composition of my news feed becomes
stable over time
so like everybody eventually sees 70
percent positive stories and 30 negative
stories or something like oh that oh the
composition could that be like you know
varying over time forever yeah so so the
so the so first of all I think the
composition a new speed would be somehow
well okay the composition is somehow
random but the probability with which
you see the thing is convergent because
that's determined basically by X
the composition of the news feed is
determined by a combination of I guess X
and Lambda right the probability of
seeing a correct story is in banking
calculator Lambda X Plus 1 minus Lambda
Q
s
but they're like size
the size of the news feed is fixed it's
not getting bigger and so there's always
some Randomness and what ends up in
there
but yeah so so this convergence will
imply for example the composition by me
you always see like three three sets in
the cap case
oh very good so so let me give you an
example right so what do the studies you
know Computing steady States from the
inflow actors function so let's look at
any strategy that which will be
important later on this is called the
majority rule okay the majority rule is
a strategy which says look at what's
here on these feed okay now share see
stories on the majority side of the news
feed
there's one caveat where you need a tie
breaking because if you see and if you
your new speed size is even if you see
six things and you see three positive
and three negative then you have the
time break in that case tie break use
your own signal Sr otherwise ignore your
signal
that's the definition of the majority
here I'm going to plot the inflow
accuracy function for this strategy the
majority rule with the parameters of
people C7 things have to share three and
55 of stories are accurate
right Lambda is equal to one
and buy the pre by the by the theorem
you know sort of
provided I am stable from at least one
side the intersections of the black
curve with the 45 degree diagonal line
our steady state these are things which
get converged through with power's
probability in particular notice that
we've got over there
a steady state which is with the
bioaccuracy of less than 0.5
the serum is telling you you get there
with positive probability and what
happens there is this fact that he said
I was talking about earlier right so
this is a case where the virality of
false stories becomes self-sustaining
people see most people in that steady
state why is that stable well when
people see a news feed of these false
stories what most people see and you see
of these four stories even though most
stories are true because I'm waiting by
popularity they end up sharing these and
the majority will end up sharing these
stories further increases their
popularity and then people sort of stay
there even though the incoming stories
are mostly correct what's happening is
when a nude agent arrives their sharing
action tends to increase the popularity
score of the wrong story and that's how
we stay there in the bad sense
okay so far we haven't done include a
bit right so far have we done partly you
know just arbitrary strategies so so far
we only know that steady state induced
by arbitrary strategies but now let me
ask you what do steady States look like
what agents use equilibrium strategies
so let's sort of think about so what
kind of equilibrium so let's think about
player symmetric and state symmetric by
using Nash equilibrium of the M player
game I'm just going to abbreviate that
as equilibrium
and then mostly we're interested in the
limits of equilibria when a number of
players and Rose launch I'm going to
make a definition that's basically
um saying these you know the the limit
of these equilibrium for in games with
large number of players
so I'm going to fix parameters Q the
accuracy of the stories K the size and
you see see how many things you see out
of news feed Lambda the viral arguments
okay I'm going to say a particular
strategy Sigma star it's a social
equilibrium
if if it's a limit of a sequence of
equilibrium index by J where I just have
an index of societies where the number
of players approaches infinity and
they're all playing the game with those
parameters
foreign
agents do know Lambda like the
parameters like qkc Lambda are going to
become a knowledge
so basically basically social equipment
is the limit of equilibria in
increasingly larger society in some
sense this is even even though societies
are growing larger the space of
strategies isn't and so I can still have
a sense of the limit of strategies right
as a number of players because you
always see in cavalcade things no matter
how many players
makes sense to say the limit of
strategies
so really I want to look at when do we
have these misleading steady state so
I'm going to say a steady state X is
informative
if
so this I think relates to your question
they call like if Lambda X Plus 1 minus
Lambda Q is bigger than half what is
this number this is basically in the you
know what's the probability each story
in my news feed matches these things
right otherwise if it is less than half
then it's called misleading basically
and this denotes whether the sampling
accuracy which is the probability of
each sample story B imagine this thing
whether the sampling accuracy is above
or below 50 percent
okay
um
perfect
so the question here is you know when do
these misleading steady States arise in
the equilibrium
and it turns out this answer depends on
whether Lambda is above or below a
critical threshold level which is
defined in terms of whether the inflow
axis function of a particular strategy
first emits a misleading statistics
so the particular critical value we want
to look at is this value Lambda star
which is basically the lowest virality
weight
such that
the majority strategy
first has a misleading steady state of
course there are situations where no
matter where you how high Lambda is that
misleading instead the the majority rule
never has misleading statistics but
that's not interesting you usually there
will be some interior value of Lambda
where you know the majority strategy
first develops a mysterious statistic
the value of that Lambda that's called
the critical virality with Lambda Stone
but the next thing I will tell you is
that whether any social equilibrium
admits a misleading steady state depends
on
if the strategy is Sigma majority admits
one and this is really
the result that gives us large
capability in this model why in general
if you start with a strategy and ask if
it's an equilibrium that's a very hard
question because whether it's
equilibrium or not depends on what is
its induced distribution over steady
States
like whether the behavior in coding the
strategy is optimal you know even if you
know the the set of steady state that
induces you must tell me with what
probability do I get this one in the
song and that one and in general there's
no close phone characterization of the
probability with which I get to
different steady States
so it would be pretty hard to analyze
equilibrium that way on the other hand
right analyzing this strategy is very
simple again this is just you know the
in you know the info access function of
this guy just some kind of polymer
basically what we're saying is I can use
the particular strategy the majority
strategy to describe the structure of
equilibrium steady states for different
values of Lambda even without solving
out what those strategies actually looks
like and even when Sigma matured is not
a Cell by equilibrium this is not a
claim that the majority rule is an
equilibrium this is just saying I'm
defining some object using the majority
rule and I'm saying the equilibrium
Behavior changes sharply around this
value defined use in maturity
so let's look at what this how this
critical virality way um looks like so
you know in this picture in these three
pictures here I'm plotting the inflow
axis function for the majority rule for
three values of Lambda 0.3 0.6 and 0.9
for some value to K C and Q right you
can see that in the first picture I've
got one informed the steady state and
the second picture one informative
steady state in the third picture wow
I've got a mysterious steady state now
so if you just like interpolate mentally
between the second picture and the third
picture there must be some behalio
blender right between 0.6 and 0.9 where
I first get a mysterious steady state
does that make sense and it must be
somewhere between 0.67 it turns out it's
about 0.76 that's the critical biology
that's the definition of critical value
it basically looks like this right if
you mentally interpret with these two it
has to be the case that I've got a touch
Point I've got I I I just sort of I'm
just tangent to the 45 degree line and I
run off
and this is and basically the shape of
equilibrium changes sharply depending on
whether the Lambda value the prep that
the platform uses it's below or above
this 0.76 or in general above or below
this Lambda style and the next theorem
tells us tells you how the Chevrolet
equivalent will change
um okay so the key here is that under
equilibrium behavior and so not
arbitrary Behavior but you know behavior
that encodes is kind of like optimality
misleading steady states are going to
discontinuously merge at the critical
biology weight than the stuff
my virality way is weekly below Lambda
star then I can tell you the only social
equilibrium is the majority rule I think
also so so so
um the only the only equilibrium
Behavior the only equilibrium behavior
for these lower values of virality is
that people should use the maturity they
share whatever is on the majority side
in their Newsfeed and they ignore their
um their private signal except for exact
type racing
that's a content of this time
also
um
whenever I am strictly below this
critical minority weight Lambda than the
star
um this unique equilibrium also only has
a unique steady state before I told you
a particular strategy might induce
multiple steady States here I'm saying
the only equilibrium steady state
there's only one equilibrium steady
state and that equilibrium steady state
is strictly higher than Q therefore
strictly informed
I guess this is hours but the fact that
it's 300 mq is what makes the majority
do optimal the fact that it's strictly
higher than Q means whatever you're
seeing your news feed is strictly more
informative than your private signal
therefore you should always type use the
you should always use the social
information as opposed to privacy
at the critical background in the way
adds Lambda star unless we're in a case
where the majority rule just never has
never never induces a misleading
statistic but in all cases when whenever
Lambda star is interior at the critical
biology weight the majority rule does
induce a misleading statistics so there
is a missing steady state being rich
with strictly positive probability and
furthermore whenever I am strictly above
Lambda star every social equilibrium
induces at least one misleading steady
state
we so I'm not saying here what the
equilibrium strategy actually looks like
for Lambda above Lambda star in general
this may not actually be the majority
rule but whatever it is it must have at
least one mysterious text and that's I
guess the important part for welfare
um so so earlier early on I told you
about the protocols the pros and cons of
having a more viral news this is the
formalization of the disadvantage of
having a more viral news feed this
result formalizes a message right that
platform algorithm which pushed by our
content into new city that they generate
misleading steady States because this
this result is telling you as long as
you your Lambda goes above this
threshold value of Lambda star you're
going to generate these bad steady
states with positive probability if
you're below it then there's zero
probability of these attacks and for
higher Lambda is
very good so we looked at the calmness
of the pro the advantage right so let's
stare at these two pictures I showed you
earlier Lambda equals 0.3 Lambda equals
0.6 if you look at the point of
intersection indeed the point
intersection is higher the statistics
higher for the higher value of Lambda
and in terms of that to be it's true in
general so whenever for in the region
before Lambda star before this critical
um critical virality weight viral
accuracy like what fraction of score are
accorded to the stay matching story and
sampling accuracy that the probability
with which I draw correct stories
um they're both strictly increasing in
London as I make things more viral the
steady state becomes more important
that formalizes the other message I told
you earlier the benefits right of having
a more viral news feed
um because you know in some sense this
platform algorithm that which way more
heavily virality they're going to help
aggregate more information when Lambda
increases news feed stories news feed
stories become more accurate indicators
of the truth one minute
um
so in some sense we've got those
trade-off right for increasing them the
two things happen only increased Lambda
pros and cons we're going to aggregate
more information
okay up until then the star but if we go
past it then we end up creating this
kind of systemic risk right that we
generate these bad steady States
um we end up in a situation where most
people hold Wrong videos
so in some sense you can then use this
to look at a designer's question of you
know if the designer wants to maximize
even benign Nokia objective like people
sharing utility then then we can what
one thing we can show is that the
designer solution would either be
strictly Above This Lambda start or a
pro become dangerously close to them the
star so either you accept these past 30
States or you sort of play this kind of
bring this kind of brinksmanship game
and come very closely but I'm out of
time and therefore I will conclude
um I'll have to skip through the
literature including work by some people
but you know some of the people in the
audience
um so let me come to conclusion so this
is a
okay okay this is an equilibrium model
of um social media platform where people
exogenously discover stories and post on
my platform people read a small
selection of past stories and news feed
and they form beliefs and share some of
the stories that they read right
maximizing the expected number of
accurate stories that they should
I think we think of one type of
contribution here is that we're sort of
applying the stochastic approximation
tools in the equilibrium set right where
it's not arbitrary Behavior but Behavior
optimal given that this should induced
distribution of students
um
so basically we study how the sampling
which populates news feeds is Lambda
affects the long-round learning
equilibrium basically whenever your your
Lambda is low enough your priority was
low enough increasing this way creates
more informative equilibrium steady
states with no real downside but if you
push it enough to this Lambda star then
we generate these misleading equilibrium
steady States and the appearance of
these mysterious steady states are
discussed
I just wanted to Super quickly say in a
means question of why not show the
popularity it seems like on these
platforms and Twitter right-hand side or
the when you see like a thing with 10
000 retweets most users have no idea how
to make sense of 10 000 versus 20 000.
so I think it's actually a perfectly
reasonable assumption unless you're
really into users are really thoughtful
about what exactly it means in this
context for this content type it's
really not informative beyond that it's
super viral so I like your assumption
that they can't tell
can you comment on the technical
difficulty if you expect that
you said it will be technically
difficult if you add the popularity to
learn yeah because I think basically
once you add in a popularity the space
of strategies become very large
if that makes sense right because they
can see lots of different numbers right
you're conditioning on lots of different
numbers and the space of that strategy
is quite large
now we could imagine an easier version
of the problem where I don't see the
exact popularity of the store but maybe
I see some course signal about how
popular this is this is in the top 25 or
something like that
that that might be thanks
okay so thank you so much for your
attention
[Applause]
so you can calculate the problem